c'était la mauvaise surprise du jour
pour l'équipe du restaurant manitoba
dans le quartier mile ex lundi le chef
n'arrivait pas à rentrer avec quelque
chose qui bloqué la serrure
c'est tout bête était de la colle et
puis en cherchant un peu autour il a
trouvé neutre dans notre boîte aux
lettres qui nous disait qu'on avait du
sang sur les mains d'être associés au
projet du petit abattoir
un projet destiné aux petits producteurs
pour leur éviter d'avoir à faire avec
les grands abattoirs industriels
il ya deux semaines c'était le
restaurant giambi qui subissait une
irruption de militants une porcherie de
saint-hyacinthe en descente
la copropriétaire du manitoba a publié
un message au ton très conciliant pour
répondre aux voeux jan meyer nexans pas
arrêter les gens le puis je pense que
c'était une bonne idée de leur donner la
parole
mechiche d'accord avec le fait de
revendiquer certaines choses attaquez
vous êtes aux bonnes personnes en
particulier impasse clés aux industries
en voilà un visage du véganisme au
québec à qui c'est une bonne idée de
donner la parole le chef jean philippe
et moi je passe à spec faire du
vandalisme ce soit la meilleure manière
de rallier les jeunes cause ça permet de
casser du sucre sur le dos des gains de
2 auquel et vegan sont extrémistes télé
vegas et des terroristes
moi j'essaie de prêcher par la
fourchette jeu c'est prêcher par
l'humour mais pour certains comme cette
chercheuse en éthique animale les coups
d'éclat ont des vertus
ce serait inquiétant disant si un
mouvement social ne dérangeait jamais on
pourrait soupçonner ou craindre qu'il ne
qu'ils ne remettent pas encore alors le
statu quo est selon elle il faut voir au
delà de l'acte militant nourrir la
discussion publique de lancer le débat
d'attirer l'attention sur des choses qui
sont plus importantes que le dérangement
suscité par action
le débat c'est le bien-être animal les
carnivores seront peut-être plus
sensibles aux arguments d'un ancien
rôtisseurs j'ai marché revient pendant
35 ans dans le chenal placé pour faire
la morale aux gens tout ce que je sais
c'est qu'on a beau lui 5 millions
d'animaux par un au canada
on pourrait certaines journées de temps
en temps c'est exactement ce que font
les copropriétaires du manitoba qui
pense bien que les clients sauront
apprécier leur ouverture
si mathieu prost radio canada montréal